Mother's Day is approaching and the
channel wants to pay tribute to those women
who work hard to support
their families, each with their own style, each
in a different way, but in the end with
the heart of a mother who gives
everything for her children.  children, come with me to know
the story of emilia pablo
below
my name is emilia pablo and what it
means for me to be a mother is to have
many roles in one day
being a mother is a very big role
and there is no manual that tells you look at
this  It is the way of being a mother, you are
guided by your instincts, by your values,
by what you want for this boy, for that
girl, so that they can get ahead and be
God first, productive children in this
society,
a woman who always wants the best
for my children, I would say  that I am a
mother who seeks happiness for my
children for my husband for me for my
neighbors and for society the role
of today's mother is very different from what
it was for my mother we are
reeling with 22 vid  as in reality the
life of a mother and the life of a
professional that a woman can have a
home and a woman can also have a
profession at the same time and it is us
women who are playing these two
roles we are proof that
my  regular day starts at 5 in the
morning from there the routine begins to
prepare the children's backpacks to
prepare this breakfast lunch what
they are going to take to school the
shoes the socks comb the girl
the boy prepare the clothes  so
every minute is worth a lot it is very
valuable for a mother who has to
maintain the house, the home and the profession
every second every minute for me is
essential after leaving the
children at home my husband takes on the role
of mother he gives me  that support of being able to
take care of the children of my father-in-law at
home and I totally focus on what
is educational information for our
community so I already have another
role and I am already thinking about the way
I come  adding in the stories that we
need to tell the community how
nice things are happening in this country
in this city the positive stories
that information that suddenly is not
heard so much but that we know that there are
many people who are getting
ahead in las vegas in the state  from
nevada and we want to tell those stories
my greatest message is to dream to have
hopes of being able to fly much higher
than you can imagine believing in
yourself reported for the senate in spanish
natalia lanzelotti